well to me education education education
education it and the you know the big
issues are the three things I just named
in terms of foreign policy it's got to
be the Middle East it's got to be the
environment this administration has
eroded the international system and that
has all kinds of pernicious effects it
also may have had some well it may have
served their their interests are or what
they thought were our interests but
where it really hurts us is in I think
we need an international response to
environmental problems for obvious
physical reasons so environment Middle
East and domestically the only issue
that really matters to me is education
everything else is just the rivet
derivative of that
mmm